bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
publication par le magazine sciences et
avenir de la situation comparé de 512
hôpitaux français révélations sur les
taux de mortalité réaction directe de
bernard kouchner
conséquence de la crise politique et
économique à moscou les cotations des
bourses occidentales font des montagnes
russes avant la rentrée des élèves la
rentrée des profs menace de grève à
propos des heures supplémentaires les
propositions de dialogue du ministre
claude allègre
notre invité pour la deuxième fois jean
jacques goldman écrit pour céline dion
titre du nouvel album s'il suffisait
d'aimer 512 hôpitaux français classés
selon la qualité des soins celle enquête
publiée par le magazine sciences et
avenir pour quatre spécialités
orthopédique urologique cardiologie et
cirés chirurgie digestive selon
l'hôpital où l'on est soigné dans ces
catégories
le risque de mort varierait de 1 à 20
statistiques établies à partir du
fichier informatique de tous les
patients hospitalisés en 1996 dans les
établissements publics ou assimilés à
noter que les cliniques privées les
établissements dépendant de l'assistance
publique-hôpitaux de paris ne sont pas
concernés la sécurité sociale a refusé
de transmettre les données mais si
maintenant les principaux éléments
révélés par cette enquête commenté par
françoise vallée les chiffres sont ceux
de la direction des hôpitaux
l'exploitation des dossiers de 8
millions de patients hospitalisés dans
le service public
en 96 pour établir son classement le
journal s'est intéressé un secteur clé
de l'hôpital la chirurgie trois critères
ont été retenus activités notoriété et
mortalité exemple en chirurgie
orthopédique
si le chu de bordeaux est le meilleur
l'hôpital de wissembourg est le moins
performant en chirurgie digestive
montpellier 1er méru dans l'oise est
très mal notée en cardiologie
mieux vaut se faire opérer à marseille
qu'à brest et neurologie l'intervention
est plus sûre au chu de bordeaux qu'à
l'hôpital de dinan selon sciences et
avenir certains services auraient dû
être supprimés depuis longtemps
pourquoi ne voulons pas fermer des
établissements où les regrouper avec
d'autres parce que aujourd'hui il y à un
certain nombre de pouvoirs des pouvoirs
administratifs de pouvoir médicaux des
pouvoirs politiques qui sont en jeu gère
l'hôpital l'existence d'inégalités en
matière de soins n'est pas vraiment une
surprise mais ce classement des hôpitaux
révélé au grand jour suscite de
nombreuses polémiques
alors les directeurs d'hôpitaux ont jugé
arbitraire cette enquête donc de
sciences et avenir la fédération
hospitalière de france a regretté
l'aspect sensationnel et réducteur de la
présentation des chiffres sans toutefois
en contester la réalité
il est vrai qu'il faut pondérer parfois
de précision c'est que ce classement des
meilleurs et des plus mauvaises hôpitaux
de france nous sommes rendus à
wissembourg dans le bas rhin au centre
hospitalier classe est le moins
performant en matière de prothèses de
hanche reportage jérôme soûlard patrie
chômage heures le centre hospitalier de
wissembourg
au premier rang des mauvais élèves
d'après lé enquête réalisée il ya deux
ans on a enregistré un taux de
surmortalité anormalement élevés pour
les opérations concernant la pose de
prothèse de la hanche
trois des ses ports aux opérations du
col du fémur toujours des personnes
âgées dans un état de santé précaire
pour le directeur de l'hôpital les
résultats de son service n'ont rien
d'anormal
sur les quarante et une indication de
fractures qu'on a eu et 11 cas où le
chirurgien a estimé qu'il fallait quand
il essaie de faire quelque chose et a
donc posé ce qu'on avait il protesté
falic là dessus je répète je refais
international vous donne un taux de
mortalité de 33 30%
donc on est dans la statistique de n'ya
pas diaboliser donc ce résultat à
wissembourg on ne traiter que les
fractures du col du fémur effectué en
urgence sur des personnes âgées et
malades
en revanche la pose d'une prothèse
totale de la hanche comme celle ci
n'était pratiqué que dans d'autres
établissements
un acte chirurgical beaucoup moins
risqué car plus classique programmée et
proposer à des personnes plus jeunes
reste que depuis 1996 l'hôpital à
moderniser ses services et embaucher un
orthopédiste
auparavant un chirurgien généraliste
assurer seul l'ensemble des actes
chirurgicaux une époque à présent révolu
bernard kouchner bonsoir on parle de
disparités dangereuse vous avez souhaité
qu'il y ait transparence mais en même
temps vous avez un peu profonds envie de
prendre la défense de l'hôpital or c'est
un peu difficile ce soir non non c'est
pas difficile c'est nécessaire un
magazine mensuel publie des chiffres
c'est bien moi je suis pour la
transparence mais il faut les
interpréter
il faut les corriger parfois on l'a vu
certains de ces chiffres vous savez
c'est très brutal un chiffre ça veut
dire on a opéré d'une prothèse de hanche
comment est elle malade avait t'il une
maladie cardiaque les infections
secondaires ne sont pas notés qu'est-il
devenu
c'est compliqué mais je ne discutons pas
ça ce soir je pense que cela doit nous
inciter à améliorer alors les ceux qui
sont classés premiers parmi ces hôpitaux
sont très contents ceux qui sont classés
derniers vont s'améliorer déjà à
wissembourg ils le font moi je suis en
charge avec martine aubry de la santé
publique
donc il faut en permanence que cela
s'améliore il y avait un numéro d'un
autre magazine
il y a deux ans qui mettait en tête
l'hôpital qui maintenant est temps que
choses évoluent
attention aux chiffres et la réalité
c'est qu'il faut parler il ne faut rien
dissimuler et je vous rappelle que l'en
quête de sciences et avenir s'est fondé
sur des chiffres que nous avons décidé
de publier qui sans publie alors bernard
kouchner pourquoi est-ce pourquoi est ce
que vous n'avez pas plus rapidement
publié ses chiffres
et pourquoi est ce que vous ne suivez
pas l'exemple par exemple anglais de
tony blair qui a décidé qu'à partir du
15 septembre dans tous les hôpitaux on
va afficher les taux de mortalité
pourquoi pas mais d'abord j'ai publié
seriez d'accord pour le faire
attendez je réponds de questions les
chiffres ont été publiés ils sont à la
portée de tous et nous avons un
organisme qui s'appelle l'anaes qui va
mettre ensemble avec d'autres critères
des groupes de malades homogène par
exemple mais pour l'instant c'est fait
non pas encore mais il faut du temps
vous savez avec les imperfections de
cette publication ça va quand même plus
vite qu'avec la machine administrative
mais ça va pas s'arrêter
nous irons encore à l'hôpital nous
fréquentons l'hôpital après la
publication de sciences et avenir et
donc nous
vont pérenniser nous devons transformer
mettre en réseau penser au personnel
lorsqu'un service ne convient pas faut
pas fermer le service par fermer
l'hôpital
il faut l'améliorer le transforme et
l'harmoniser il faut penser aussi aux
populations autour alors c'est vrai il
ya des disparités
autant le dire comme dans tous les
métiers de la vie il ya des bons
journalistes des mauvais journalistes
dès qu'ils passent dès qu'ils reviennent
parce que je veux dire mais oui très
bien je vois pas qui vous pensez métrage
merci beaucoup bernard kouchner à moscou
la visite de bill clinton a quelque peu
perturbé les débats de politique
intérieure au lendemain du refus par la
douma la chambre basse du parlement
russe de voter la confiance à victor
tchernomirdine le président américain a
exprimé son soutien à boris eltsine
rendant hommage à sa capacité de
résistance mais il n'y a pas eu de
discussions sur une aide financière à la
russie or cette rencontre la vie
économique et financière russe est
toujours bloquée commentaire de notre
correspondant permanent à moscou gilles
rabin
même dans les voyages officiels les plus
graves il y a des moments de détente
visite de l'école primaire où le
compositeur rachmaninoff avait appris à
lire ses premiers mots sinon ses
premières notes de musique
la première personne à parler n'est pas
bill mais hillary clinton
je connais dit elle un américain qui a
découvert votre pays quand il était
encore étudiant il est de retour à
moscou
ce geste de tendresse sera très
certainement autant commenté par les
médias américains que les images de
boris eltsine tel que nous l'avons vu ce
matin ces quelques gestes protocolaire
traditionnel semblait demandé au
président russe
un effort qui n'épuise la crise
économique qui frappe la russie après en
avoir parlé bien sûr dans le secret du
tête à tête avec helsinn bill clinton
l'a abordé devant les étudiants de
moscou son discours s'adresser
évidemment aussi au futur gouvernement
russe ne fait pas marcher la planche à
billets dit il traiter correctement vos
créanciers respecter les règles du
marché qui s'impose à tous
ne soyez pas découragés
ne vous laissez pas abattre continuer
seulement à travailler si vous le faites
la russie pourra décoller comme une
fusée vous êtes debout depuis seulement
sept cents le président américain est
applaudi par les étudiants et les
étudiantes comme aucun dirigeant russe
ne l'a jamais été
avisant soudain un jeune homme à la
cravate trop voyante bill clinton fait
lever le fautif la cravate est aux
couleurs du drapeau américain
depuis hier les cotations boursières
enregistre des variations très
importantes un petit peu partout dans le
monde avec de fortes baisses mais aussi
quelques hausse cet après midi un
véritable jeu de montagnes russes il
veut bien accepter cette image
explications jean paul chapelle
depuis 24 heures ou un street mène la
danse une danse folle qui entraîne dans
sa crise de nerfs toutes les places
financières de la planète
tout commence hier soir une sévère
correction infligée à nouveau à la
bourse de new york - 6,3 pour cent à la
clôture c'est la deuxième plus forte
baisse de son histoire en une journée
est parti en fumée
l'équivalent du budget de l'allemagne
une vague de panique
très contagieuse empêtré dans sa propre
crise bancaire tokyo n'avait pas besoin
de ça la bourse atteint son plus bas
niveau depuis 12 ans nouvelle chute
nouveau redressement pour finir un peu
au dessus du niveau de la veille
tokyo sont d'or paris s'éveille
contaminés par la nervosité -2 4% à
l'ouverture
- 0-15 à la clôture pour le cac 40
c'est la cinquième journée consécutive
de baisse
retour à new york aujourd'hui comme hier
wall street commence par baisser en
provenance de moscou
aucune bonne nouvelle mais réaction et
contrecoup de la chute
certains opérateurs rachètent plus de 2%
à la mi-journée
pas de quoi se rassurer hier à la même
heure le dow jones n'avait pas encore
flanché appel général leclerc parle de
danse folle de fébrilité la février tel
et les financiers aiment pas trop ça
comme la nature les financiers ont
horreur du vide et le vide est ici
d'abord politique en russie bien sûr
toujours en attente d'un gouvernement
après avoir unilatéralement décidé de
retarder le remboursement de ses dettes
mais vite de politique également au
japon qui ne parvient pas à prendre des
mesures de redressement économique
nécessaire et plus généralement
faiblesse des institutions et des pays
occidentaux clinton et les scandales le
collant difficile campagne électorale le
fmi sans le sou y at il encore un pilote
dans l'avion s'interrogent les marchés
alors cela dit la russie n'est que
l'élément déclencheur d'une purge qui
était qui était attendu sur les marchés
financiers à commencer par wall street
la bourse américaine avait vu sa cote
doublé en trois ans une exubérance
irrationnelle selon le président de la
réserve fédérale qui appelait tôt ou
tard une sévère correction
c'est aujourd'hui chose faite alors est
ce qu'on peut parler d'un
d'une prochaine récession mondiale
écoutez le scénario catastrophe existe
la faillite de la russie risque
d'inciter les investisseurs
internationaux à durcir les conditions
de prêts aux pays émergents d'europe
centrale et surtout d'amérique du sud ce
qui précipiterait ces pays dans la crise
plus grave les américains ménages et
entreprises ont énormément joué en
bourse tant qu'elle monteil profiter de
leurs gains pour consommer et investir
si elles chutent trop brutalement et
bien sûr ce sera l'un vertes donc le
risque de récession
mais on n'en est pas encore là où le
street n'a perdu que 20 % la croissance
américaine reste saine avec toujours la
possibilité pour la soutenir de baisser
encore un peu les taux d'intérêt aux
états unis la comète pour la france
écoutez en deux mots l'europe et l'euro
semble la protéger ce qui ne veut pas
dire qu'elles sortir indemne les crises
asiatique et russe c'est un demi point
de croissance perdue cette année et sans
doute quelques dixièmes en moins l'an
prochain donc toi dès que la traduction
concrète un reflux un peu plus loin du
chômage
merci gerin à 48 heures de la rentrée
scolaire pour les élèves du primaire et
des collèges ce sont les professeurs qui
reprendront demain contact avec leur
établissement de modifications
importantes des conditions de travail et
de rémunération des professeurs voulue
par le ministre claude allègre suscite
des inquiétudes voire des préavis de
grève tout d'abord les effets de la
déconcentration c'est à dire des prises
de décisions concernant les clauses
d'enseignants titulaires non fixe à deux
jours de reprendre le travail des
professeurs ne savent pas où ils seront
affectés voici des exemples de deux
enseignants et grenoble et lyon avec le
reportage de nathalie moisan et régis
mater
à quelques jours de la rentrée les profs
ne sont pas toujours les mieux préparés
eh bien le rectorat m'avait envoyé un
courrier fin juillet kim annoncé une
affectation pour fin août seulement
et à ce jour je n'ai toujours pas de
réponse je ne sais pas dans quel
établissement je suis affecté pour
satané pas d'autre réponse qu'une lettre
lui demandant d'attendre
impossible dès lors de mettre à profit
l'été pour préparer les cours
hélène peut avoir n'importe quelle
classe de la sixième à la terminale
autre inconvénient elle peut être nommé
n'importe où dans son académie alors
qu'elle habite dans le sud de celle ci
autre académie celle de lyon et même
situation pour damien auxquels
l'administration n'a toujours pas donné
de réponse
alors vous avez un peu n'ont toujours
pas de poste à la veille de la rentrée
avant vers la rentrée pas de fausses une
incertitude qui préparent parfois des
déceptions il y a deux ans damien avait
été nommé en français la veille de la
rentrée alors qu'il est prof d'histoire
surtout une situation qui ne prend pas
en compte l'intérêt des élèves qu'est ce
qu'on peut penser en fait d'un fort
essor de distorsion graphique est nommé
sur un poste de français ça n'est pas
respectée les rsa n'est pas respectée
les parents
une situation qui dès lors ne satisfait
personne
si je suis affecté tard le jour de la
rentrée même d'ailleurs la veille
il faut quand même avoir le temps
d'aller sur place trouver un logement
d'appoint parce que faire 300 kilomètres
ce n'est pas possible pour aller
travailler
on trouve bien évidemment aussi des
parents en leur disant que ya zéro
défaut en fait en fait effectivement
peut-être qu'il y aura un professeur
devant chaque classe mais pas forcément
le bon professeur au bon moment des
incohérences qui selon certains
syndicats pourraient se généraliser l'an
prochain avec la régionalisation du
système de mutation des enseignants
alors second sujet d'inquiétude nous en
parlerons avec claude allègre dans
quelques instants et l'une des raisons
du dépôt de trois préavis de grève folle
à entrer les heures supplémentaires un
nouveau calcul sur la base du nombre de
semaines réellement travaillées
entraînerait selon les syndicats une
perte de salaire importantes
reportage jean bernard schmidt et
raymond schappler dans deux jours c'est
avec ses élèves qu'isabelle franchira
les grilles de son collège
pour l'instant il lui reste surtout à
prendre connaissance de son emploi du
temps
professeur certifié d'histoire
géographie isabelle doit assurer 18
heures de cours hebdomadaires elle s'est
déjà comme tous les autres profs qu'elle
fera obligatoirement au moins une heure
supplémentaire par semaine
problème le ministre vient d'annoncer
une baisse de 17 % du taux de
rémunération des heures sup
d'où une certaine amertume on nous
impose une baisse sur quelque chose qui
nous est dû aux dj déjà ardue par
imposer on n'a pas le choix beaucoup de
collègues choisissent de faire des
heures supplémentaires tout ce que nos
salaires sont quand même relativement
bloqué depuis un certain temps de la
fonction publique
je trouve que c'est assez cynique
jusqu'à présent une heure supplémentaire
effectué chaque semaine rapportée 7580
francs un professeur certifié avec cette
baisse de rémunération
le manque à gagner sera de 1280 francs
la raison de ces économies pour claude
allègre le financement des emplois
jeunes motif invoqué pour baisser le
tarif
selon le ministre les heures sup ne
devraient pas être payés pendant l'été
car les profs ne travaille pas je suis
parti avec mon cartable
dire que mon cartable ça fait quasiment
la moitié du coffre quand je parle
puisque j'ai plusieurs niveaux de classe
et j'ai préparé mes cours pendant mes
deux mois d'été
donc je travaille pendant mes vacances
selon plusieurs syndicats la suppression
des 800 milles supplémentaires
existantes pourrait permettre la
création de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de postes de professeurs
la manoeuvre n'est pas si simple
d'autant qu'un minimum d'heures en plus
apporte une certaine flexibilité aux
systèmes leur suppression totale
rendrait le système trop rigide et ne
nous permettrait plus cette souplesse
pour l'organisation de nos enseignements
dans nos établissements
aujourd'hui au ministère on s'affirme
prêt à discuter
le temps presse la plupart des syndicats
appellent à boycotter les heures
supplémentaires dès la rentrée
le collègue rebond soir il ya un vrai
débat sur les heures supplémentaires
commençons par ce qu'on venait
d'entendre est-ce qu effectivement
voulait supprimer complètement le débat
il n'y a pas de débat pour moi ya pas de
débat
je suis à la fois pour des opérations
claire réel 16 heures supplémentaires
annuelles bâtiment où les gens là cela
laissait 36 semaines
y'a pas de raison mais payé 42 semaines
et toutes manières travail qu'on en
était que me disent elles n'en attendait
de l'été ils touchent leur salaire
on paye pas des heures supplémentaires
qui sont pas faites est ce que vous être
payer d'heures supplémentaires mais ce
que vous ne les faites par notre support
saignant et ben pourquoi il les
enseignants ça serait différent
les heures supplémentaires je suis pour
les heures supplémentaires faites sont
payés comme tout le monde
deuxièmement 6 heures supplémentaires à
d'autres que moi s'en sont aperçus que
c'était anormal c'est à dire les
fonctionnaires de bercy
mais moi j'ai choisi de prendre les
devants grâce à ses heures
supplémentaires n'ont fait que j'ai
récupéré gcrai 40000 emplois jeunes
quinze mille personnes c'est là que
pardon mais c'est là qu'il ya débat
parce qu'on dit venir créer des emplois
jeunes dont des emplois précaires soient
pérennes nom et ton qu est ce que vous
ne crée pas des emplois fixes mais parce
que par contrat à durée indéterminée
parce que vous pouvez pas comme tout le
monde demandé à ce que le nombre de
fonctionnaires en france navre
n'augmentent pas et demander au premier
degré les fonctionnaires premier
ministre
apprenez tenu compte de l'opinion
générale on a décidé de le gel des
fonctionnaires mais est ce que
réellement non mercato nationale a
besoin des emplois-jeunes bien l'emploi
jeunes mais aussi d'emploi finans n'y at
il eu
actuellement il ya une décroissance des
élèves du nombre d'élèves est ce que
nous demandait le ministère des finances
était de supprimer des postes de
professeurs
eh bien on en supprime rapport on n'en
créera en fait 3300 là cette année oui
et et deuxièmement et deuxièmement les
emplois jeunes c'est la révolution dans
l'éducation
ça permet aux maîtres de s'appuyer sur
quelqu'un qu'il l'aide qu'ils ne se
substituent ça les enseignants c'est des
aides éducateurs mais vous aimez cesco
ce dont on a besoin l'enseignement est
en train d'évoluer
les nouvelles technologies rendent dans
l'enseignement les tout le monde a droit
à l'accès à la culture à la au sport etc
c'est ça qui permet de 2,7 cette
attitude que vous décrivez est qui et
qui n'est pas l'attitude de la majorité
des enseignants est une attitude qui
n'est pas très à mon alarme sociale non
mais je voudrais vous dire combien ça va
pénaliser les enseignants 130 francs par
mois pour créer 40 milles entre emplois
jeunes pour moi c'est là ça la
solidarité nationale et moi je suis fier
que l'éducation nationale ils sont très
bien payés quel pour quelques-uns et
l'on mélange bien entendre de dire qu'
ils ont été revalorisées plusieurs fois
je viens d'entendre dire quelqu'un
disant la fonction publique a été gelé
ces pauvres elle a été revalorisé par
lionel jospin
on a mis 23 milliards de revalorisation
la fonctionnalité de la fonction
publique notamment les enseignants
alors elle représente la moitié non mais
attendez on est dans une période de
chômage
- mon combat c'est sortir les jeunes du
chômage c'est aider les jeunes
on a créé 40 mille emplois jeunes on a
repris la totalité des maîtres
auxiliaires
ça c'est ma politique est la démarche
pour les maîtres auxiliaires ça c'est
fait c'est fait c'est fait et alors pas
de caisse que la fréquence du diabète là
avec ce ton là est ce qu effectivement
par exemple est-ce que vous avez
rencontré le snes on a dit que vous
alliez le voir aujourd'hui vous savez je
vais vous répondre là-dessus mais je
voudrais commenter si vous voulez bien
la première partie oui
la plénière par les questions je vais
faire des réunions non parce que vous
avez fait moi je veux commenter les deux
choses la première partie vous justifiez
entièrement à ma politique
pourquoi il ya des retards dans
l'affectation de quelques professeurs
car c'est quand même la mienne minorité
indienne ne pas citer leur pardon
monsieur le ministre mais il ya une
opacité totale sur les chiffres les
rectorats veulent pas nous les forêts
bien sûr pour une raison à cause du
mouvement national puisque ces faits
nationalement il faut le temps que ça
soit fait pour gérer nationalement pour
ajuster nationalement des mouvements qui
concerne 150 mille personnes personne ne
gère nationalement centralisée cent
cinquante mille personnes
quand ça va être déconcentré il n'y aura
plus à 6 jeux déconcentre pas par un
culte la déconcentration
je me déconcentre pour mettre les gens
plus près de la décision et moins
d'opacité précisément donc vous m'avez
bien vous faites ce que gaston defferre
a fait pour la descente rennais
absolument bon alors maintenant je vous
réponds j'ai vu je suis ouvert à tous
les dialogues g d'une chose très claire
on l'a vu on l'a vu avec les enseignants
du primaire on avec les étudiants on l'a
vu avec tout le monde donc aujourd'hui
effectivement j'ai rencontré une des
syndicats sur le sdz oui ton de snes
j'ai rencontré le snes très longuement
et ça va mieux entre vous à une
atmosphère
détendu appartement où on veut avancer
ensemble sur les sur les les problèmes
certaines des revendications sont
justifiées n'avait pas parlé c'est
d'ailleurs d'indications technique sur
les hors classe où les choses comme ça
d'autres revendications sont encore plus
justifié par exemple les concours de
recrutement qui dont les postes ne sont
pas pourvus et donc on tombe d'accord
sur un certain nombre de malades on
pourra pas tout abordé il vous a fait ce
petit de français qui va passer dans les
collèges c'est parfait julian notre
ancien patron qui avait sa jeu il fait
des citations des croisières j'aurais
savoir ce qui vous va le mieux les
chiens aboient la caravane passe ou qui
n'entend qu'une cloche n'entend qu'un
son qu'est ce que vous préférez des deux
le premier est naturellement le premier
naturellement ben oui parce que le
deuxième ils savent que c'est un peu
stalinien
on l'a reproché un petit peu quelquefois
non personne ne m'a jamais reproché de
ne pas écouter non non non c'est pas
vrai je crois qu'il faut le la méthode
jospin et vous là il a rappelé sait on
écoute on discute on dialogue et puis on
décide et ce n'est pas la minorité et
c'est pas la minorité qui décide pour la
majorité c'est vrai pour les sans
papiers c'est vrai pour l'éducation
nationale merci claude allègre c'est
aujourd'hui qu'entre est en vigueur les
premières mesures du budget 99
concernant la gratuité de la carte
d'identité la suppression de la taxe
d'examen sur permis de conduire et la
baisse des droits de mutation un
allègement fiscal estimé au total à un
peu moins de 5 milliards de francs
ouverture en début d'après-midi à fleury
mérogis dans un gymnase de
l'administration pénitentiaire du procès
de 138 personnes impliquées dans le
réseau islamiste baptisé chalabi du nom
de l'un des principaux prévenus
c'est le plus grand procès d'islamistes
jamais tenu en france mais les
conditions que celui ci ne sont pas
équitables selon les défenseurs
les avocats vont donc quitter le gymnase
en fin d'après midi reportage pascal
tous ces bons luc bachofen parti se veut
solennel
les visages sont fermés un tel boycott
judiciaire n'arrive pas si souvent
c'est près de la moitié des avocats de
la défense qui quittent l'audience ils
viennent de demander le renvoi de ce
procès nous connaissons les états les
pays où la justice est rendue dans les
stades ou dans les forts militaires ou
dans les prisons
c'est inacceptable pour nous et nous le
refusons nous sommes partis mais nous
allons nous concerter pour voir comment
saisir la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme
comment saisir la cour de cassation de
ces violations de droits que représente
un tel procès
c'était le dilemme de l'après midi pour
les quelques défenseurs encore indécis
quitter les lieux pour protester mais
ainsi abandonné leurs clients ou au
contraire rester malgré les conditions
particulières de l'aude gens qui y en a
qui veulent pas d'effort il y en a qui
veulent défendre internat qui considère
que la place de l'avocat doit être la
moins je pense que l'avocat quel qu'il
soit quel que soit le procès sa place
est dans le prétoire pour assurer la
défense de la personne qui doit être
jugé les avocats n'aime décidément pas
cette salle située trop près de la
prison distille et surtout ils détestent
de cette audience fleuve avec 138
prévenu qu'ils ne se connaissent pas
tous entre eux et au degré de
responsabilité très divers le parquet de
paris leur réponds que la compréhension
des réseaux est à ce prix et qu'il y a
quelques mois des avocats le même
réclamait le rassemblement des dossiers
l'audience d'aujourd'hui était chaotique
elle devrait reprendre plus calmement
demain après midi
dominique verdeilhan vous aide dans ce
gymnase judiciaire enfin vous avez passé
l'après midi est ce que le procès va
continuer oui tout à fait parce que le
tribunal a rejeté la demande de renvoi
plus exactement elle a décidé de prendre
une décision plus tard ce qui veut dire
que le procès continue et cela veut dire
aussi qu'on peut parier qu'un certain
nombre des avocats qui ont aujourd'hui
claqué la porte seront demain à la
reprise de l'audience alors c'est vrai
que tout le monde a du mal à se
persuader que nous sommes ici dans une
salle d'audience et non dans un gymnase
d'où cet après midi une ambiance très
particulière on vous l'a dit des avocats
très remonté on part on ne part pas la
même fait savoir déjà qu'il ferait citer
le juge bruguière qui a mené
l'instruction et charles pasqua des
prévenus étonnamment décontracté pour
des terroristes présumés 24 prévenu dans
le box que vous découvrez derrière moi
114 libre assis au milieu de la salle
les prévenus qui applaudissent comme au
spectacle lors des plaidoiries de leurs
conseils ou qui se lèvent lorsque m de
félice demande le renvoi de ce procès
quant à mohamed chaïbi celui qui a bien
donné involontairement son nom à ce
réseau est bien il est le seul
aujourd'hui à faire une déclaration
politique
je ne suis pas algérien dit il je suis
de nationalité musulmane
je n'ai rien à voir avec la junte
militaire alors grand procès oui par le
nombre il a fallu pas moins de trois
heures pour que le président fasse
l'appel des 138 prévenu grands dossiers
c'est encore à voir il faut rappeler que
nous ne jugeons pas ici les attentats de
paris de 1995 ni leur préparation mais
des faits bien antérieur merci dominique
un policier de la brigade anti
criminelle de tarn placé en garde à vue
le policier a tué par balles un homme
qui devait demander une cigarette une
violente altercation aurait suivi de
policiers en civil a attiré alors que
l'homme s'enfuyait c'est l'inspection
générale de la police nationale igpn qui
a été chargée de l'enquêté sur cette
bavure mortels reportage à tarbes
christophe la rocca olivier combe
férid ben fatima avait 31 ans il était
le père de deux enfants
c'est dans cette ruelle qu'il a été
abattu hier soir vers 21h par un
policier en civil
à l'origine une banale altercation
devant ce tabac eric ben fatima demande
une cigarette le policier la lui refuse
en lui précisant que la mendicité est
interdite à tarbes
la suite s'est déroulé sous les yeux de
ces trois lycéens après sébastien
alabarbe sont tombés par terre sans
relever
il s'est encore avérée mais le sig avait
toujours le tokyo que les partis en
courant le plus il a subi et là dans la
rue moi j'étais ici quoi et
j'en voyais qu'il était en train
d'essayer de sortir son arme il est
hormis la tournée et là il a
il ya des bénévoles non mais je les vis
de propulser kanu fois sur le sol
deux fois élu combien de temps entre le
moment où le jeune est parti en courant
et le moment où le policier a tiré six
secondes
la consommation aucune sommation aucune
selon la police la victime était un sdf
il s'agit en fait d'un rmiste qui ne
possédait pas d'antécédents judiciaires
grave
le policier qui appartient à la brigade
anticriminalité de tarbes se trouve
toujours en garde à vue
ce qui est sûr c'est que dans sa
déclaration le policier dit qu'il s'est
senti menacé par la victime
l'enquète a été confiée à la police des
polices l'igpn les amis d'éric eux
appellent à une manifestation pacifique
vendredi prochain au havre les chances
d'une poursuite de l'activité du
chantier naval sont très faibles
1900 salariés sont menacés de
licenciement des ateliers et chantiers
du havre ne peuvent pas survivre sans
l'arrivée d'un nouvel actionnaire
un rapport d'experts commandé par le
gouvernement avancent même l'hypothèse
de tournai franchement la page de la
construction naval war
reportage dans les chantiers navals
havrais de laurent bailly et yann
streiff les ateliers et chantiers navals
du havre n'a guère l'orgueil de la seine
maritime depuis un demi-siècle des
générations d'ouvriers sont encore 2000
aujourd'hui sur le site construit des
navires marchands
mais à la fin de l'an 2000 l'entreprise
risquent de mettre la clé sous la porte
alors le pdg essaye de motiver des
salariés démoralisés et inquiète
espérée d'abord que bruxelles autorise
l'état qui a déjà versé plus d'un
milliard à soutenir ces chantiers
pendant deux ans encore espérer surtout
qu'un grand groupe rachète l'entreprise
le pdg a un mois pour trouver un sauveur
c'est pour l'instant un sursis et ça
peut devenir les conditions d'une
réussite à long terme les espoirs de
reprise par les grands groupes
ce confetti mais vous êtes en
négociation actuellement avec un
repreneur
on n'en est pas là l'urgence c'est
d'abord de terminer ces trois tanker
commandé par un armateur norvégien comme
la direction la cgt explique que c'est
une commande empoisonné qui fait perdre
de l'argent à l'entreprise alors ici
tous les salariés redoutent la faillite
et ses conséquences pour nova chômage
depuis pas pour la région france le
beaucoup des voix elle évoque d'ailleurs
deux sapeurs en ville les havrais
rencontrés au hasard se sentent
concernés eux aussi se disent inquiets
bon c'est que d'avoir un impact sur la
ville oh oui ça fait comme comment comme
un charbon ce volet là d'arsenal qui
ferment sur charbourg ya déjà pas mal de
chômage par ici alors là c'est comme ça
l'entend plus
aujourd'hui le patron des ateliers et
chantiers navals du havre n'a rassuré
personne
les salariés n'ont au mieux que deux ans
de travail devant eux mais lui n'a que
trente jours pour enrayer ce compte à
rebours qui risque d'être fatal à
l'entreprise un an jour pour jour après
le décès de la princesse diana c'est une
star du football david ginola qui
reprend son rôle en faveur de
l'élimination des mines antipersonnel
diana s'étaient déplacés dans les
bidonvilles de luanda en angola
aujourd'hui c'est donc david ginola qui
a repris le parrainage de la campagne de
la croix rouge contre ces mines il
participait à un match amical de
football en compagnie de jeunes et
d'enfants victimes de ces mines
reportage à nos consignes est roger
motte c'est peut-être partie les
footballeurs et parce que ses jambes
sont en or que david ginola fait un bon
ambassadeur du combat pour
l'interdiction totale et mondial des
mines antipersonnel les engins qui ont
coupé les jambes et les genoux de jeunes
angolais fou de foot comme tous les
gosses dur
l'herbe est moins verte ici qu'à londres
mais le match sera inoubliable salon
viennent directement sur leur terrain
jouer avec des des jeunes qui ont qui
avait envie de devenir footballeur et
qui ont eu un malheur dans leur vie
parce que la connerie humaine à fécamp
quand qu'on fasse des choses horribles
en angola les mines les explosifs menace
des enfants à chaque coin de champ de
chemin
l'école dispense donc des cours sur les
mines avec pièce de théâtre pédagogiques
dans les versions de sensibilisation de
la croix rouge
sensibilisation ici des enfants ailleurs
des gouvernements les inciter à ratifier
le traité d'interdiction des mines
antipersonnel signé l'an dernier
il faut 40 pays qui doivent ratifier la
convention qu'elles deviennent
exécutoires on en est à 31 alors encore
un petit effort on arrivera 40
mais sur les 125 pays qui ont promis de
ratifier on sait que des pays
extrêmement important comme la chine
comme l'inde comme le pakistan comme les
états unis n'ont pas encore signé
non mais si important soit-il le prêter
ne règle pas le problème les zones déjà
numéro fort est ici la piste comme ceux
du talent dans ce sens et toute cette
partie qui longe le talus qu'on voit là
un merlon s'appelle à merlon est miné
l'aéroport de huambo est un cas d'école
on estime que 20 mille mine d'or mais
ici en deux ans de travail 36 des
mineurs n'ont sorti que lui sans honneur
républicain et présidentielle en fin de
matinée à l'elysée pour les 22 joueurs
de l'équipe de france de football ils
ont reçu la légion d'honneur et monsieur
chirac a affirmé qu'en la france veut
elle peut au ruban rouge à la
boutonnière les champions du monde sont
repartis à clairefontaine pour préparer
le prochain match france islande
reportage laurent frédéric bollée gens
connus comme cadeau il y avait plus
original à des maillots numéro 23 le
président en avait déjà un
au moins tant pis les joueurs et aimé
jacquet ont offert bien plus à jacques
chirac et au pays la coupe du monde
alors cette semaine plus tard pour une
remise de légion d'honneur bien mérité
cela valait bien la peine de revenir
selon heures les jeunes donneurs c'est
vrai que ça mon honneur mais voilà ça
fait c'est sympa c'est sympa
ça connaître ici bah ouais ça troisième
fois en quatre ans le chouchou du public
reste quand même
zinédine zidane et les célébrations il
commence à connaître
et voilà comment se conclut une belle et
grande aventure qui a fait sortir toute
la france dans la rue un certain soir de
juillet des moments que personne n'a
oublié tous bords politiques confondus
le remerciement est unanime
merci les bleus pour ces moments uniques
que vous nous avez fait vivre
merci pour ce bonheur immense merci pour
la leçon de tolérance et d'humanité que
vous nous laissez mention spéciale à
aimé jacquet l'ex entraîneur des bleus
s'était fait discret ces derniers temps
la preuve sans doute d'une indéniable
sagesse oui on est touchant et muet puis
surtout il me semble que on a tous un
petit peu
en retour sûr sûr sûr toute sa vie donc
on ça défile et très rapidement dans ma
tête en tout cas direction claire
fontaine cet après midi à voir la foule
on a l'impression qu'on est toujours au
mois de juillet même ferveur même lieu
mais désormais ce sont d'autres matches
qu'il faut préparer voici maintenant un
couple exceptionnel de la chanson céline
dion et jean jacques goldman ils sont
associés pour un nouvel album de 12
titres signés goldman céline dion et
jean jacques goldman avait déjà
travaillé ensemble en 1996 cette fois-ci
l'album s'intitule s'il suffisait
d'aimer
et pendant que la chanteuse québécoise
est en tournée aux états unis jean
jacques goldman s'est confiée à louis
carzou et jean-françois chevet
lorsqu'il revient au studio méga près de
paris jean jacques goldman se laisserait
presque aller à 3 note de nostalgie
c'est ici qu'il a réussi à retrouver
l'une de ses interprètes préférés
céline dion
réussi car depuis leur premier disque la
québécoise est passé par la case titanic
et quand on a vendu une chanson à 23
millions d'exemplaires le principal
problème devient l'emploi du temps
jean-jacques ne présenter des chansons
et évidemment ça a été ça a été un grand
coup de foudre et gt2 de savoir que je
te pour retravailler avec jean-jacques à
nouveau donc au mois d'avril on s'est
revus pour l'enregistrement du disque et
à l'intérêt d'une semaine on a tout fait
tu as deux trois sets par soir
moi je me sens la situation d'un auteur
compositeur à qui on donne une voix
exceptionnelle que n'importe quel auteur
compositeur souhaite avoir
c'est un rêve un rêve pour le moins
récurrents la dernière fois que jean
jacques goldman et céline dion ont
partagé leur emploi du temps
ils étaient plus de 11 millions à se
laisser bercer par leur partition
voilà vous la retrouverez prochainement
dans envoyé spécial je crois avant de
refermer ce journal je vous rappelle la
principale information que nous avons
développé la publication par le magazine
sciences et avenir de la situation
comparée de 512 hôpitaux français
révélations sur les taux de mortalité
des risques de 1 à 20 à des risques de
mort de l'un à 20 selon les hôpitaux
dans un instant la météo avec nathalie
rihouet à 20h50 un film de pierre
richard et avec richard et smaïn le
dernier journal perd 0 1 heure 30 sera
présenté par florence duprat demain 750
yannick letranchant recevra pour les 4
vérités marc blondel le secrétaire
général de force ouvrière à demain 20h
bonsoir merci